bienvenue est venu sur diagonale tv
poursuit eva ces huitièmes de finale de
championnat du monde féminin 2015 avec
marie sebag toujours en course
qualifiées pour ces huitièmes de finale
après avoir éliminé en 16e a rappelé au
monde 2012
rihanna a choisi l'un qui avait gagné le
titre en 2012 alors qui reste-t-il c'est
peut-être le moment de faire un petit
bilan pour savoir qui il reste dans ce
championnat quand même avant de voir
cette première team match aller de ces
16e de finale les stars regardons un
petit peu un pic on y roule indienne est
toujours là elle se balade marque g20
jusqu'à présent pas de tie break c'est
elle écrase ses adversaires on à
alexandra kosteniuk l'ex-champion du
monde aussi on à antoine et à stefano
vice champion du monde et puis on a
aussi bien sûr piquera ming avec une
énorme expérience et souza au ici donc
la dernière chinoise alors qu'elles
étaient les chinoises
près de sept ou huit au départ je sais
plus chiffre exact mais il y avait une
grosse délégation chinoise yan applique
une voilà donc elles se sont fait quand
même éliminé malgré leur présence dans
les dix premières joueuses mondiales
eh bien ils n'ont pas réussi à
progresser dans ce championnat du monde
donc on va maintenant regarder cette
partie sans plus tarder entre eux marie
sebag et donc natalia pogo nina la russe
dans un match qui va s'avérer
extrêmement tendues encore une fois
puisque les joueuses sont de très bon
niveau toutes les deux c'est parti e4 e5
4e 3 cavaye m6 kbc 6 pardon foulée 5
alors là propose une espagnole donc à
noter un que cette ouverture n'a pas été
vu pour l'instant par marie dans ce
championnat puisqu'elle s'est heurtée
surtout à des sicilienne on peut jouer à
6 avec une espagnole ou alors on peut
jouer ce que je joue pour rooney n'a
bien entendu qu'alexis la fameuse
défense de berlin popularisée par
kramnik lors de son match par kasparov
en l'an 2000 et puis aussi qui a été
jouée par anand lors de son match contre
carsen aux championnats du monde 2014 et
qu'on a vu dans plusieurs vidéos et
c'est très dur à passer comme défense
très solide
la grande des deux variantes c'est de
jouer petit rock et puis ensuite de
jouer des 4 ou de jouer des quatre tout
de suite voilà mais ici
et bien mari choisit des 3 voilà ça
évite les grandes variantes
c'est pas plus mal pourquoi pas fous ces
cinq petit rock pas grand chose à dire
ça c'est des coûts calée des quatre
alors attention ça attaque le fou ça
propose un échange en f3 faut sans doute
prendre ce que fait marié pas de
problème évidemment on prend en d4 1
vous prend et maintenant c'est trois
logiques classiques on joue ces 3
pourquoi parce que bien le fou en b 5
peut se faire harceler ses six b5 et
bien ils viendront à 4 il viendra en c2
voilà en c2 il protégera le pion aux 4
et puis si ça s'ouvre belle aura une
belle diagonale et puis aussi on joue
ces trois pour jouer des 4 bien entendu
plus tard on veut jouer des quatre pour
essayer de prendre position sur le
centre précise tout à fait normal
d'aller à trois très bien maintenant
kaya 3 le coup c'est 3 permet aussi
d'envisager de développer le cavalier
via ses deux trois voire même pourquoi
pas ces quatre attaquants le fou b6 et
le pion aux cinq cd possibilité plein de
choses sont possibles il faut juste
faire attention c'est 6 x 4
fourcade puisque marie se dit peut-être
qu'elle veut mettre son cavalier en ckd
justement petit rock ou g5
ils sont fous angers saint cloud
lecavalier 6 ceci est normal
ashes pose la question au fond est-ce
que tu prends le cavalier et tu le
donnes la fameuse paire de faux
attention puisque en finale la paire de
fou peut s'avérer extrêmement
dangereuses ou h4 normal nous c'est
cette poussée de e.on mais le fou en c2
puisqu'il a plus rien à faire sur cette
petite diagonale puisqu'il heurter ses 6
il aurait pu peut-être pu venir en b 3
au 6 mai et mari préfère le positionner
en c2 pour avoir un oeil sur quatre
puisque les noirs peuvent aussi jouer
des 5 et mettre un peu de pression sur
le centre donc ici elle est tranquille
le problème de jouer en france et 2
c'est que le car il ya 3 peut pas tout
de suite venu en c2 il peut passer
peut-être par ces quatre mais pas tout
de suite puisque b5 voilà les noirs
jouent b5 pour prendre de l'espace à les
dames c'est assez classique et ce
faisant il enlève aussi la casse ces
quatre cavaliers du fonds sans doute au
bon moment puisque ce qu'allait pour
l'instant bombay peut pas vraiment
sortir de sa position mais on va voir
que marie a tout prévu des quatre
simplement on commença aussi pour les
blancs à faire pression sur le centre
ont menacé sans doute puis on prend fou
prend suivi de f4 avec une domination
centrale e5 est ce fou devient
extrêmement dangereux ils visent leur
aucun carrément il peut menacer des
maths avec la dame qui viendra en d3
avec une batterie fouda attention il
faut faire un faute prudent donc dé 6,1
voilà les noirs protègent leur centre
ils veulent garder ce pion 4
ficelez parle par le point 5 de façon à
ce que ce fou ne vivent pas et reste en
défense et la regarder tranquillement
marie se pressent pas fou des trois là
ça c'est très bien et pourquoi elle veut
libérer la classement son cavalier voilà
c'est tout simplement il faut recentrer
ce cavalier qui pour l'instant bon mais
mal placé sur le côté
voilà le laisse pas comme ça traînait il
faut que des pièces jouent au maximum de
leurs possibilités
si possible vers le centre ouvert des
cases intéressante mais pas dans des
positions comme ça où elles sont un peu
hors jeu j'ai 5
c'est un coup responsable puisque ça
affaiblit le rock attention ses pions ne
protège plus le roi de la même façon on
est bien calé au tour du roi ici mais
bon ça pose la question fou évidemment
il faut s'en aller dams est
tranquillement coup de damas alors si
classique pourquoi parce qu'on va jouer
le foot aux routards ici puis les tours
sont liés on enlève la dame pour que les
tours puis ce communiqué est aussi ces
dames bien sûr protégé à 15 5 1 qui sont
quand même commencer à être un tout
petit peu sous pression
voilà tour eu un très bien sûr protège 4
attention parce qu'il peut y avoir des
prix sinon des quatre il y avait quand
même dame cavaliers contre quatre il y
aurait des cloches possible sans doute
c'était pas bon mais c'est pas plus mal
de deux façons c'est thomas paris
stephen vu qu'on pourra pas jouer
4 maintenant qu'il a agi 5 et 5 ont la
meilleur e un protège 4 quand le centre
s'ouvre allait bien placés sous les 6
bien joué des noirs c'est pas mauvais
coup bien entendu je fais pression à
genas de gagner un pion tout simplement
aucun en d4 clavel est cédé au bon
moment voilà ça y est le cavalier vient
protéger
pas de problème développement harmonieux
des deux côtés pas de problème un fou 17
hélas h3 petit coup de marie tranquille
3 pourquoi pas on bh3 empêche des idées
à base d'oeuf ou g4 attaque la dame ou
simplement prépare aussi une possibilité
pour le fou devenir âge de ce fou
pourrait se faire attaquer par exemple
par cavaye âge c'est encore pas tout de
suite si la dame mais si cette dame joue
kvh 5 c'est pas un problème dans ce cas
là on pourrait revenir en h2 même si
après cavaliers à une belle case en f4
bien de bien entendu ça peut être une
idée on se ménage aussi une possibilité
pour le roi bon ça c'est pour beaucoup
plus tard est bon un oeil sur cette
classe g 4 pourquoi pas pas facile de
trouver des coûts la position est serré
pour l'instant tfd 8
alors ça c'est pas mal on sort du tour
et puis on a le fameux vis-à-vis on en a
parlé dès lors des parties précédentes
cg magra d'avoir une table en face d'une
tour si sa sour au centre bell et à la
fin il ya une tour qui attaquent la dame
par exemple imaginer qu'on enlève les
pions et puis à fou prend h3 et
vis-à-vis tours dale qui peut être
pénible
donc il faut faire attention marie sort
saddam d'un f3 très bien à noter que bas
et je fais un tout petit peu pression
sur m6 bon c'est pas très grave mais vu
qu'il ya plus le pion g7 c'est pas
pareil hein défendu que par la dame donc
il faut faire attention
l'adami s'ils ne risquent rien f3 alors
c'est aussi l'idée d' h 3 voilà ça
révèle le coup c'est à dire que
maintenant il n'ya pas fou j'ai 4 alors
si on n'avait pas joué h3 il y aurait eu
peut-être fou g4 la dame est embêté se
fout pas rien pouvant aller en 1 h 5
puis angers 6 participants la défense du
roi attaquant aux 4 c'est une
possibilité pour les noirs 20 jou h 30
un rêve toutes ses possibilités et on
joue d'abord f3 comme les noirs ont joué
dans le set afin de lier les tours voilà
c'est tout maintenant sont liés on peut
venir au centre
voilà regardé comme le développement se
fait de façon précise à chaque conte
tout en ayant la volonté de sortir
toutes ses pièces au maximum et de les
activer au maximum cavalier e 8 pourquoi
pas
un plan des noirs qui aussi cherchent
des coûts passe c'est pas évident pour
un non plus c'est leur pièce comme un
peu un tout petit peu
embourbé là le fou 17 bouche là la tour
à tour des huit développement qui est
peut-être pas très très harmonieux même
si ça a l'air encore correct cavaillon 8
bon c'est pourquoi pas il veut sans
doute venir angers7
aufeminin com je sais être remplacé le
pion qui est partie par un cavalier
sachant que c'est vrai que souvent
cavalier près du roi ça défend bien pas
toujours ça dépend des fois mais c'est
raide en pleine situation c'est vrai que
c'est un excellent défenseur
le retour à des magnifiques tranquille
en r&d sai et toutes les pièces de marie
ont été développés le rock a été
effectué tout est en place pour
envisager très bientôt des actions de
rupture
encore faut-il retrouver qu'avec g7 dont
six compagnies bon pourquoi pas elle
préfère mettre le client j7 que en uf6
sauf que ça prend du coup quand même un
peu long et a tranquillement nord il se
presse pas
d'abord elle joue [ __ ] f1 alors
pourquoi faut il faire un bep sans doute
parce que ça laisse la tour maintenant
protéger des 4 donc c'est intéressant
par ailleurs en d3 de toute façon se
fout n'avait pas d'actions sur cette
diagonale puisqu'il ya le pion aux 4
donc quitte à garder cette diagonale
autant le mettre en f1 et laisser les
tours être active
voilà replace une la pièce sans doute à
sa meilleure case met donc en plus des 4
est protégé par la tour on peut
envisager des valeurs à base de
caudillos 3 suivi 2 attention danger des
possibilités de cavaler g4 attaque le
fameux pions h si si si faible et si le
roi vient le défendre il ya un cavalier
six échecs possible voyez donc le fait
de rejouer cette manne de cavaliers
affaibli la case et fils est ce que
c'était vraiment nécessaire
il aurait pu alors et puis aussi laisser
le cas vaillant et si ces jouets roi g7
cognizant donc fou c'est 7
et là c'est l'heure pour marie alors
très jolie inattendu un peu si on veut
mais bon si on voit que toutes les
pièces blanches sont quasiment à leur
maximum en termes de potentiel et
position on sait que c'est l'heure de
tenter des trucs
alors quoi tenter il faut en plus c'est
d'ouvrir le jeu maintenant qu'on est
bien placé alors que les noirs bons sont
peut-être maladroitement placer ce
clavier papa l'air top la case m6 est
faible à 15 h 6 est faible on voit que
ce cavalier est à deux pas de venir
justement taquiner ses cases bon il ya
le fou ici qui pourra s'échanger
donc si on arrive à les ministres ou
c'est pas plus mal et puis on octroie
aussi on peut viser la case excellent et
on peut viser la classe des cinq qui
pour l'instant ils protégés par le pion
c6 bon tout ça donne des idées avarie c4
très jolie c4 et jolie sa garde un
maximum de pression maintenant il ya
pression en b 5 puis quel fou en plus
derrière la pression 1,5
si les noirs prennent ils activent les
pièces blanches car si je prends ans
s'écarte jeu mais le fou en c4 je visais
vii avec la dame
en plus je contrôle la case centrale des
si je prends en d4
eh bien j abandonne un peu le centre
serge et plus de pions au sein mais
l'enjeu pourrait pousser le 5 avec les
blancs pour créer des ruptures en plus
en d4 je peux reprendre du cavalier sarr
créer plus de menace sur b 5 enfin voilà
donc c'est pas bien pour les noirs de
prendre donc qu'ils défendent
ça a l'air encore solide et la marijuana
tranquillement travailler trois très
bien voilà donc tous âges
ce explique que la tour d un protège des
4 on peut jouer qu'à rio 3 c'est ce
qu'on disait le fou qui était en d3 est
venue en f1 ce qui libère le fait de
surprotéger le pion libère le cavalier
et sa cavale et maintenant il peut aller
soit en j'éclate parfois pour attaquer
h6 et m6 pourquoi pas en rêve 5
si les noirs prennent bien on prendrait
du pion et puis un vis-à-vis tour dames
derrière il peut se passer des trucs
bref la tension a l'air al'avantage
blanc on peut pas dire que ce soit
encore venir décisifs mais ça existe
tours 8 codina ne panique pas elle
surprotège le poignet belgique le 5 il
faut tenir le centre il faut pas
permettre aux blindes eux d'ouvrir ne
faut pas non plus lâcher cette case de 5
parce que tant que la case de seine qui
est là tant que le pion aux 4 et la
bombe et se fout notamment il est il est
pas trop trop fort il faut éviter que ça
souvent parce qu'avec les tours derrière
c'est chaud et on reste encore sept
tours à huit capes a été placée non plus
voilà tranquille mari se pressent pas
très joli magnifique des quatre très
bien alors des 4 un des intérêts de b4
c'est d'empêcher parfois des csn qui du
côté noir c'est 5,4 et les contrôles
très bien et ça permet aussi surtout
parce que ces 5 c'est quand même un peu
faiblard ça laisse la classe des ce1 aux
cavaliers attaque la dame la case m6 est
faible il ya des échecs on voit tout de
6 et 5 est pas bon alors il faut
imaginer qu'on arrive à contrôler des
scènes pour les noirs mais surtout en
fait oui b4 propose éventuellement de
jouer c'est simple sur un néant
surprotéger cette case et on va casser
cette mine chaîne de pions des six va
sauter ascend va sauter le fou g3 va se
réveiller que la seule pièce blanche qui
pour l'instant but
lisons sur du mu sur un mur sur du béton
et tout le jeu va exploser la alors
après c'est pas forcément ça sera pas
forcément décisif mais ça fait peur
quand même parce que les noirs là son
corps une sous pression une non moins
l'espace bon tour à des huit voilà en
prévision d'une ouverture centrale tour
à des 8 et une autre idée on voit tout
de suite très jolie des cinq super ça
c'est l'autre idée des scènes ça c'est
l'idée qu'il y assez 4 aussi et
maintenant qu'on a joué regardez b4
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
maintenant qu'on a joué dessins sur
c'est celle que je peux prendre
imaginons c5 ce serait pas terrible
5 simplement on prend ces 5 et après la
prise à seyssel belge est un pion passé
tout simplement déjà au centre ici puis
on passe est protégé par une tour voilà
ça suffit pour dire les blancs
l'avantagent les n'auront pas
l'équivalent il faut que les noirs fasse
attention plus hauts pics et des 6 et
les blancs plus d'espacé en plus
maintenant s'éprend bessengue menace
avec ouverture pourquoi pas du jeu c'est
celle peut s'avérer faible aussi bon
voilà petit avantage blanc durable des 5
c'est pénible parce que l'idée de des
cinq essais il ya une autre idée
derrière s'est prononcé six et j'élimine
un défenseur de cette fameuse case des
cinq mon cavalier ne fait qu'une chose
c'est rêver d'y aller alors ils
annoncent ils font reprend quand le
cavalier viège peut toujours prendre du
fou mais j'ai donné la paire de fou j'ai
donné la paire de fou et cette petite
chaîne de pions devient faible aussi
parce que c'est prend apprend fou prend
en envoyer toutes et tous a faibli
ensuite à cette manoeuvre
magnifique bien préparés anne marie
voyer com est là c'est pas pressés à
l'abord jouer b4 et maintenant des cinq
donc là déjà on peut considérer que
positionne helmand les blancs les blancs
sont mieux alors la regarder d'ailleurs
ça se voit tout de suite puisque
toi fuite ça veut dire que pour unis la
sépaq enjoué fouet fuite torreilles
fuite assez faiblard quoi la torah les
venues en des 8 au début rappelez vous
après 1,8 pour protéger le sel bon
maintenant que saint chrême plus rien
puisqu'on a joué des scènes qu'il ya
plus de prises en 5 l horreur et fuite
bon mais en fuite si c'est pour jouer 5
g pas sûr que ce soit une très très
bonne idée parce que ça affaiblit
d'autant plus encore le roi noir
bon ça protège simplement mari
maintenant je vous la variante puis on
prend force et vous prend et maintenant
tout simplement s'éprend apprend
et
maintenant regardez magnifique variante
très jolie pas facile à voir les blancs
jouent et gagnent en coups alors gagne
d'avoir sais pas si clair mais facile
c'est clair mais on va voir que la
partie il ya des ressources sous prend
des cinq superbes alors ça c'est la
combine qu'il fallait voir c'est quoi
l'idée c'est que ben en fait nan il faut
prendre des mesures que donne un fou
mais ça permet aux cavaliers de venir en
d5 et après
alors imaginons que les noirs les noirs
n'ont pas repris imaginons que les noirs
reprennent tout simplement joujou câbles
et des cinq attaques
le fou c'est sète où va la dame elle est
attaquée aussi si je joue sur une case e
8 ou
alors 8 se serait pas bon du tout parce
qu'ils auraient cavalli six échecs et la
dame est perdu et si je vais en 17 avec
la dame ya encore quarante six échecs et
la dame est perdue donc la dame est
obligé de venir en russie ce pas le
choix sinon il ya la fourchette est
maintenant simplement je récupère la
pièce avec en plus double attaque d'un
me fous et donc les blancs sont mieux
ils ont gagné du matériel avec en plus
ici d'options passé lié ils sont passées
est liée
ce qui est énorme donc c'est très très
mal barré pour les noirs voilà donc il
faut pas surtout pas prendre il faut
prendre 5 et pour nina natalia pour nina
ne s'y trompe pas elle joue fou à 8
voilà ce fou doit être gardée pour
s'échanger canton ce cavalier qui sinon
ce sera beaucoup trop fort alors marie
se pressent pas fous ces quatre très
bien alors en plus ça cloue le fameux
play offs est ce qui fait que les noirs
peuvent pas envisager d obscène de toute
façon même s'il avait envie de le faire
je passe sur ce soit bon en plus
attention au f5 qui quand même faisable
parce que le fou à 8 ici effectivement
attrape attaque
la dame est europe après aux cadres donc
si le fcm on peut pas prendre cinq sinon
elle avait perdu donc il ya quand même
une petite menace en jouant tous ces
quatre jeux l'éliminent voilà là les
noirs jouent sans doute un bon coup
fourré 6
c'est pas mal pour essayer de se
défendre ils sont clairement moins bien
foulée si ce qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
faire ben ils veulent prendre ce
cavalier ils veulent l'éliminer parce
qu'ils ont bien compris que six
cavaliers arriva en d5 c'est la cata or
les blancs pouvaient menacer aussi fou
des cinq pour éliminer le x 8 et enfin
venir avec cavaliers des cinq avec un
cavalier énormissime au centre en plus
j'ai la colonne c'est chez les pions
passé liée autant dire ça va être une
boucherie et la mari s'y trompe pas
regardez il y avait d'autres idées
derrière le cavalier ou 3 parce qu'il
visait on l'avait dit viser
un des 5 il vise et pourquoi pas être
celle qu'on avait dit aussi mais est
visé aussi g4 aïe aïe aïe
le cavalier énormissime qui menacent
d'aller soit f6 son âge si ce faire un
échec au roi prendre un pion
beaucoup de menaces quoi pénible donc la
prog nina jour ueaj cette moindre mal
sur un échec mais simplement il revient
sans doute soit je suis soit le vit à
angers 6 et on sait ce qui va se passer
car les six échecs 3g 6 voiles alors le
roi risque pas trop trop enlevée 6 parce
que le fou ne peut pas justement il ya
le pur ou quatre qui le bouche voilà il
peut pas venir l'embêter et la case h5
est bien protégé aussi il n'ya pas
d'échec supplémentaire au hcr
bon mais c'est quand même on n'aime pas
trop alors voila moi je pense que c'est
quand même chemin mais regardez quand
même qu'aux cavalli justement
heureusement qu'il est là cette fois on
voit bien qu'ils protègent les cases
essentiel est là on regarde et hop
après en passant par là on a forcé le
roi a monté et la jolie pouf
mais là je suis comme des steaks c'est
pas mal vous prend or là déjà il ya un
petit problème c'est qu'ici il ya deux
possibilités pour reprendre on prend pas
des pions parce que si on prend du plomb
sa bouche
la diagonale du fou sa bouche la
faiblesse des six salles s le pion aux
cinq fort aux cendres et f5 va suivre
avec une marée de pions certainement pas
du pion on mais on peut prendre du fou
ou de la tour et prend du fou me sens
meilleur parce que bon me trompe
peut-être évidemment mais fou prend il
contrôle la case et 8
bon j'ai deux pions passé là je vais
jouer à quatre à cinq nouvelles fois ci
vient à cette b5 b6 ça va vite
et s'il ya un des coaches peut envisager
même de sacrifier la tour contre le fou
peut-être pas tout de suite mais au bon
moment sachant qu'en plus comme le roi
est un peu faible puisqu'il est sorti
bombay et je pourrais sans doute prendre
le fou puis récupéré le pion des quatre
est derrière comme j'ai deux puits
reliés
aidé par un fou je vais récupérer la
qualité est sans doute beaucoup plus
quand je passais un plan à long terme
qui marchait ces liens l'autre idée de
marie est plus tactique mais je pense
c'est un peu moins fort quand même parce
qu'elle joue tout reprendre et c'est bon
c'est pas mal pour prendre des 5
bien sûr c'est pas un mauvais coup je
vais pas dire que c'est un mauvais coup
mais la tourbe ont aussi une pièce à
longue portée qui vise la qui tape sur
le pion à l'or alors qu'elle tape aussi
bien si elle est là le fou c'est papa il
tape pas sur le pion ils visaient la
casa 8
bon là que mes phares à tour là parce
que si on double les tourbains food et
quatre de la part des noirs et des
parkas et m6 et on se dit que ben c'est
bouchema tourne mal placé et finalement
je suis pas sûr que ce soit bien placé
là elle est devant les pions souvent on
a mis un préfère avoir les tours
derrière les pions bon je suis pas sûr
soyez ce soit top
ceci étant dit c'est au noir de jouer
les noirs font nos gaffe énorme
cavaliers 6 c'est une gaffe alors pas
facile à voir mais marie trouve la suite
en partie elle joue un bon coup un autre
coup possible
on pouvait aussi jouer faire tout
reprendre en d6 regarder la madame c'est
parce qu'elle fait mais c'est quasiment
pas rien pour prendre les six très
intéressant sacrifice de tous rangs oui
mais ça marche pas on peut pas prendre
avec les noirs parce que si on prend de
la dame simplement d'un échec
moi j'ai 7 et au regard des maintenant
fou prend attaque le roi un échec et la
dame qui sera perdue donc on récupère la
dame contre tours est fou ce qui est une
excellente opération et plus les pions
plus depuis longtemps dire que c'est
archi gagnant puisque on avait déjà un
point de plus et l'autre prise c'est un
peu pareil c'est à dire si on prend de
la tour simplement on fait
d'un échec 3g s'est efforcé ainsi au
virage 5 on se fait mater par x 2,3 g 7
et maintenant on prend pas non pas du
fou mais de la dame
puisqu'on fait échec et la batterie d'un
me fous attaque la tour on va récupérer
la tour et on a gobé deux pions un deux
trois pions de plus plus la paire de fou
donc la partie est finie en fait on à
son cavalier aussi ce tour prendre les
six gagnés tout de suite bon mari joue
dame f5 échec
d'abord c'est un peu pareil sur oise 5
fu de maths
donc il ne reste que roy g7 alors le
problème là c'est qu'on est depuis
quinze coups en quasi cette note pour
marine dans la salle il faut le signaler
puisque il ne restait à marie la queue
une dizaine de minutes voire cinq
minutes il reste très peu de temps pour
arriver au 40e coup ça c'est le problème
elle réfléchit beaucoup aux alentours du
20e coup beaucoup trop donc là pour
trouver le coup pour prendre des six
faut quand même avoir le coeur bien
accroché parce que c'est quand même on
donne une tour bon ceci dit ça marche
bien ça marche toujours aussi bien pour
prendre les six que font les noirs la
menace c'est fou prend eu cinq échecs et
c'est une catastrophe
il ya tout qui tendent et en plus on
attaque le fou il ya le pion aux six
aussi qui est le pion lecavalier 6 qui
attaque et que font les noirs que font
le nord une défense possible un essai de
défense et de jouer cavalier des quatre
attaques la dame mais simplement on joue
d'en prendre cinq attaques la dame et le
roi donc enfin échec oran et dames donc
il faut prendre fonds prend échec au roi
m6 puisque f6 simplement par l'échec
tout en attaquant le fou ce qui est
toujours très bien et l'aller les blancs
ont peuvent jouer tranquillement coup
comme par exemple effectivement tout
reprend b6 et après qu'elle prend 2,5
ils ont quand même trois pions plus plus
fous contre onze cavaliers se fou qui
peut d'ailleurs toujours revenir en des
cinq ans visant la casa 8 de promotion
donc c'est une partie très très agréable
à jouer avec l'énorme avantage de bons
donc la marine malheureusement ne voit
pas secousses tactique tout reprendre
des six pourtant bombay était une des
justifications de prendre de la tour
plutôt que du fou très certainement mais
il lui reste peu de temps la pendule
donc problème de temps pour mari et elle
joue plutôt le coup h4 en se disant bon
tout est en prison sent bien qu'il ya
plein possibilité d'échec partout il y
aurait 5 ou un jour h4 l'augmentent la
pression sur le roi adverse c'est pas
tout à fait faux mais ça laisse les
noirs revenir en jeu qu'à valider quatre
voilà j'attaque la dame on va pas
prendre de la tour il va pas donné la
qualité gratuitement puisque maintenant
il y aura foule prend et il n'y a pas
grand chose et on voit que d'ailleurs
c'est au tour maintenant on est mal
placé un les coincer dans le camp ennemi
bon allez imprenable ceci dit mais on
voit pas bien ce qu'elles attaquent un
enfin si elle a fait pression quand même
sur les pions
qu'ils sont bien défendus bon et où va
la dame alors d'alger cas semble logique
qu'un jeu clou le pion g51j l'empêchent
de prendre
hélas les forces actives tour c'est 8
c'est plus la même c'est plus la même
d'une gros avantage possible en jouant
la variante qu'on a vu marie se retrouve
en position délicate parce que la trop
longue ça devient faible et les noirs
pour la première fois la partie ont
commencé à pouvoir activer ou valve fout
pas évident des trois tours c'est 3 à
pogo nina prend sa chance à fond
tour d un mari doit jouer vite il reste
très peu de temps la pendule tours à
huit attaques le pion à 2 protection de
marie et après tour c4 40e coup il faut
que marie joue un coup attention lors
d'ailleurs ici il ya d'ailleurs une
foule signaler les noix aurait pu jouer
un coup très intéressant regardez très
jolie pas facile avoir pour projet 3 et
wii très chaud alors pourquoi mais parce
que regarder il ya le fou ici qui vise
le roi donc si on prend du plomb il ya
une découverte du cavalier premier point
et si je prends de la dame avait le
cavalier des 4 vient à eux deux échecs
auront un avec la fameuse fourchette au
royal le roi bouche et la dame est
perdue donc tout reproche d'être ont été
très forts et on était obligé de
reprendre du pillon il faut prendre
sinon on perd et là maintenant les noirs
auraient pu jouer simplement cavaliers
ces deux échecs du fou leroy gyan h2 et
maintenant regardez simplement cavaliers
3 et triple fourchette tripes
la dame jour on récupère une tour est
bon les noirs ont une position très
certainement équilibrée y maintenant
parce qu'on a en plus les foudres
couleurs opposées
et c'est sans doute une finale qui le
peuvent tenir sans problème banlieue
noire on palpe les blancs d'oeufs
tombe pas un désavantage quand même dans
cette variante mais l'égalité est
obtenue complètement pour le nord alors
après tout bien les normes plutôt tour
c4 regardez quand les pièces mort d'un
coup sont toutes actives la torah 8 tab
sera de la tour et sur la colonne c'est
le fou vise le roi il protège le
cavalier des quatre qui est
magnifiquement place et voyez comment
quelques coups il suffit d'une erreur et
l'activité a changé de camp mais bon les
blancs ne risque pas grand-chose
opposition est très solide très saine
donc il n'y a pas de faiblesse forte il
va falloir sans doute lâché le pion de
b4 on pourra pas le protéger mais bon on
peut encore jouer c'est le 40e coup le
tour prendre b4
donc il ya trente minutes de plus à la
pendule donc lamari a pu recommencer à
jouer alors là ce qui s'est passé après
f4 et bien bizarrement c'est pogo nina
cette fois à l'intérieur pour glénat qui
s'est bien réfléchir beaucoup et donc
dans dans cette fin de partie en fait
partie c'est l'inversé qui s'est produit
c'est la russe qui est passé en
territoire négatif au niveau du temps
donc qui a commencé à perdre beaucoup de
temps à la pendule pour réfléchir c'est
vrai que le coût de mariée très fort f4
le roi noir est en difficulté attention
menace d'ouvrir les lignes face à ce roi
mais c'est dangereux parce que regarder
en cas de prise du pion h il ya
notamment regarder ici il y aura un
touriste chèque et où va le roi parce
que si leur avis en géant je vous
rappelle qu' un fou
donc cette cette menace d'ouverture ici
peut se faire peut-être avez le plus
bref mais peut-être pas avec le pion h à
cause de cet échec ici qui pourrait
s'avérer plus que pénible ça pour être
gagnée dans certaines circonstances
donc il faut faire attention parce que
ce roi la blanc il est quasiment sûr un
couloir sur la colonne h
donc faut peut-être pas s'amuser trop
avec ce pion h et prendre angers 5 sans
réfléchir aux conséquences
donc les noirs ici n'ont pas trop le
choix quand même il va falloir prendre
ce pion s on peut pas prendre du plomb g
puisqu'il est cloué reste l'autre
possibilité se prend et heureusement que
marianne un calcul est fou prend en
marche ce qui est pas évident puisqu'il
ya quand même une astuce pour des côtes
et non ici maintenant ces dames si ça
c'est un peu pénible pour les pour les
blancs puisque là où va la dame
sachant que si la dame vit à angers 3
pour garder parce que le problème c'est
que si sylvain veut garder la dame on
vit à angers 3 pour garder le pion cloud
et sinon on perd le fou mais si on vit
en g3 et le cavalier ici vient en veut
deux fourchettes
donc on perd aussi le fou donc on n'a
pas le choix font prendre
il n'y a pas de choix en fait voilà mais
après la prise au regard des f3 attaque
la tour et le fou toujours attaquer
heureusement ouf
sûr que c'est pas si mal il avait vu
mais ça marche vous prend des six
j'enlève l'attaquent du fou et si la
toux est attaquée à l'autre aussi
ouf d'accord alors si les noirs jouent
aux kamikazes de type en jouant par
exemple ici
tout reprend bien ce qui est une
possibilité
eh bien les blancs pourrait jouer
simplement tout reprend bien et ça
continue de marcher puisque après pions
prend tour simplement on peut encore
prendre le fou vous voyez ça marche
c'est un peu délicat
c'est un peu acrobatique mais ça
fonctionne donc après on prend des 5 fu
prend b4 et maintenant les noirs jouent
des près de 4 alors bilan des courses
ici ben évidemment l'avantagent de
mariée a fondu comme neige au soleil
mais il reste quand même un petit peu un
petit avantage pour les blancs pourquoi
parce que d'abord un oeil à la paire de
fou père de fou c'est très très puissant
bon ça c'est le premier point ça a l'air
de rien mais en finale
c'est pénible c'est à dire que là alors
c'est d'autant plus pénibles qu'il ya
des pions des deux côtés il reste encore
le pion à ne rien y compte ce pion est
ici bon il ya encore une prise en cours
ici mais bon c'est au volant de jouer il
ya des prix ce possible il restera quand
même un pion que j'ai donc il ya des
plans des deux côtés avec la paire de
fou bon on pourrait imaginer après aussi
tout un tas des changes arriver là ni
finale touré fou contre tours bon et
parfois ça gagner celle-là
rappelez vous un philidor analyse du jeu
d'échecs encore une fois 18e siècle il
le disait déjà et puis ça a été analysée
plein fois depuis ça peut gagner et puis
bon avec des pions on peut on peut
envisager de faire des dames bien
entendu bon il ya deux pièces qui
peuvent se sacrifier mais il reste du
matériel du matériel bon et un petit
avantage aux blancs sans doute pas
décisif sur un jeu précis mais quand
même fou ces trois ont déjà un problème
pour les noirs tout âge
heureusement la tour va pouvoir protéger
et on peut pas rajouter de pression sur
trois alors à noter que si on joue en
des huit on peut si on protège en dix
huit on libère à le pion à qui peut
avancer à quatre à cinq attaques le fou
il continue d'avancer créant et puis on
passait donc le mieux c'est de protéger
par à 4 voilà à 4 je protège de la même
façon sauf que j'empêche que le pion de
jouer je protège le clouage pas trop le
choix
et là maintenant les bleus en profitent
pour prendre le 4 alors ils auraient pu
blanc d'abord prendre d'abord un g5
prise prises puis prendre qu'à mon mari
choisit de prendre à un cadre d'abord et
en se disant c'est peut-être pas grave
que les nom prénom âge quatre mois je
suis pas sûr donc moi j'aurais préféré
prendre d'abord je pense que finale est
un peu mieux si les blancs prennent bon
si fils est expliqué ici mais on verra
peut-être plus tard donc là on est dans
une finale davantage blanc a quand même
fondu mais bon on est encore des quoi
jouer tomber un attaque le faux bond pas
forcément super idée je sais pas tout
c'est cet échec 3-3 je monte le cavalier
est cloué attention si la tour bouge je
peux prendre mais attention la tour
pourrait venir en a3 ici le fou est
cloué menace qu à genoux tour b3 peu à
mon très tôt à trois jeux clou le fou
donc je peux pas prendre le cavalier
mais tourbe et 3 jeux des clous et le
cavalier peut pas prendre puisqu'il est
prouvé
et si les noirs prennent la tour
simplement je reprends du pion et la
finale ça sera des finales pièces
légères c'est pas la même donc
faut 5 food et celle qu ici pour les
blancs protège le pion à 2 et la peau f6
très bien je me rapproche du fou ça me
permet d'envisager de libérer mon
cavalier mais tombé 4 vous tombez 4
intéressant évidemment les noirs ont
deux pièces attaqué tour et cavaliers
mais tu auras trois clous le fou on
vient de le voir
heureusement il ya un autre coup qui
permet de déclarer c'est fou b3 et ça
permet de transposer c'est quasiment
forcé le nom puisque là il ya le
cavalier qui attaque et sykael et bouge
bien espalion de trouver des bonnes
cases il va y avoir des échecs derrière
est ce que le foot tient c'est pas sur
un donc il va falloir pour les noirs
prendre moi pas rentrer dans les détails
parce que savait trop long cavalier
prend et donc la liquidation après fou
prend 1 5 3 prend 1,5 et à prend b3 et
bien les blancs ont sans doute obtenu ce
qu'il voulait c'est à dire une finale
deux tours légèrement avantageuse
puisque nous pillons acheter a de toute
façon on est perdus c'est sûr on va pas
le protéger avec les noirs prochain coup
là je me dois de le prendre avec le roi
s'il a tout revient à 2 pour prostate à
quai le pion g2 si leur apprend et on
prend de la tour voilà donc ce pion est
perdu et ce plan-là reste faible ceci
dit la position est peut-être la finale
et peut-être quand même nul qu on dit
souvent les finales tour sont toutes
nuls déjà roi touré pions contre roy
s'est souvent nul surtout quand le roi
noir ici peut venir devant le pion pour
l'instant il peut et bon là le problème
c'est que si les blancs avance ses pions
il faudrait que le royal
si le roi il va ils vont perdre l'autre
pions bon bref donc on a l'impression
que ça va finir par une nulle torah 2
quand même on regarde la suite tout
proche 4 c'est ce qu'on avait dix tours
b 2e attaque le pion b3 font revenir en
d4
on aurait pu pousser beckham est tombé
classe sans doute mieux puisque la tour
a pas beaucoup d espace lounge 5 leroy
maintenant bien protéger son pion très
important là peut-être un coup apprécié
de marie qui joue
j'ai quatre échecs pas sur ce soit mieux
que je pense que j'ai trois meilleurs
parce que tant que le puritain b3 la
tour peut pas venir l'embêter bon et
enjoint g3 je peux assez de faire des
échecs pour repousser le roi et maître
leroy angers 4 devant le pion si le
pilotage étroit en plus c'est difficile
pour les noirs de venir embêter les
blancs en bas puisque dès que j'attaque
la tour il faut qu'elle reparte
bon je me sens que j'ai 3 est plus
prudent mais bon je trouve c'est pareil
je sais pas échec
angers 6 mois j'ai trois maris
maintenant on va tenter des choses
trois bien trois f4 pourquoi pas torres
un échec c'est le problème
5 tomber un bref 4 aurait fait un chèque
on hésite note du côté des filles ici
deux minutes un marine minutes pour
natalia pogo nina donc roger trois
plongées un échec les coûts sont pas
toujours forcément optimum roef trois
tours f1 échec pas facile roigé deux
tours d un copain tour b5 sa croupe un
petit peu le roi noir tour des 3 sa
croupe laurent blanc a coupé coupé et
demi et là les blancs commencent à
pousser leurs pions
bon pourquoi pas est ce que ça peut
suffire tomber trois wild 2
six coups d'attentats tout ça échec en
espérant sans doute que le roi vient
d'en haut 6-3 sel comme un astre
princesse avec échec et après on reprend
pour le pion je sais pas il faut faire
attention roger 6 et 5
les blancs continuent à pousser leurs
pions roigé cette tour ses 5,3 g 6 tours
des cinq ans réussit ce tour c'est 5 3
et 6 est bon il faut pas répéter les
coups sûrs mais aussi de gagner les
blancs quand même mon avantage ils
essaient de gagner quand même rose 2
pourquoi pas on réussisse toujours
attentes 5 échecs
moi j'ai six pour faire attention parce
qu'évidemment si les bleu et blanc
viennent avec le roi ici mais collet
noir il va prendre ce pion ce pion à je
vais avancer on sacrifie à la limite
presque la tour contre le pion si le roi
peut venir protéger le pion qui avance à
pas de problème justement c'est tout pas
si simple thorois d2 alors tourner
quatre tombes et 4 à l'intéressé que ça
attaque le pion et ça empêche le pion
blanc la dame en c3 c3 boom tourangelle
4 voilà donc là si on se dit c'est
probablement nulle puisque maintenant
évidemment le pion h20 contrebalancer le
pion b des blancs bon attention la tour
aussi est attaqué pour ses cinq tours
chez 1
c'est sans doute un bon coup je veux
contrôler par la 8e donc on avance le
roi bonne chose là c'était l'heure pour
les noirs de jouer h5
il fallait jouer street commencé à jouer
5 très vite on n'a pas peur d'eux b6 on
joue simplement probablement
l'échec un crack il ya des petites
choses parce que si on fait les chèques
3,5 on menace tourbe est celle qui est
la tour peut pas prendre mais c'est
peut-être que le pion noah arrive quand
même à damas évite tout simplement
il y aura des rencontres d'âmes
peut-être à la fin ça sera nul aussi
faut calculer ça bon tour b un échec
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il fait froid
c'est la torah riche et pourquoi pas
c'était toujours encore leur pour pour
pousser ont permis au roi blanc d'alors
en la halle aux draps blancs et devant
le pion si le roi et deux dans le pion
on peut pas pousser b5 et sailor les
noirs se disent de pousser acheter
maintenant très bien 3 c'est cette aile
et blanc veulent pousser adam un ouais
c'est une bonne idée alors les noirs
auraient pu jouer ici torah 5
intéressant puisque si on pousse b6 tout
reprend échec
et puis on a gagné on avait la partie
parce que après le pion mais encore deux
cases on va l'arrêter avec la tour et le
pion à je peux a décidé donc droite
troisième force presque reçoit rossé 6
oui il faut protéger le pion bessin
croit ces six sous
hourra b6 mérovée 6 on a le roi devant
le pire non plus tu auras c6 mais
c'était possible suroît c6 tend à
s'inverser si ce peut être que le world
tour à 8 et s'allier la tour et sur la
huitième et bon peut-être ça empêche la
dame bon h4 voilà c'est une faute les
noirs se disent ici voilà ce roi c'est
cette île se disent moi aussi je pousse
le pion est bien là s'appelle la
position est nul ici à condition de
jouer tour à 5
en fait seules trouvent trop bien c'est
dire que la hache 4 pers pourquoi alors
c'est chaud a expliqué mais en gros le
roi noir est coupée voilà donc les
blancs ont tout le temps par exemple sur
h3 de joué-lès-tours c3 le clan pouces
tourache 3 et 6 dames je prends d'accord
il requiert il va vite adam lui
par ailleurs le roi est coupée donc
imaginons que je pousse que la tour se
sacrifie contre la dame je pousse je
pousse à la fin je peux faire un tour en
c1 le roi n'est plus coupée ils avancent
tous rachats mais il a pas le temps de
venir protéger le pion yves à angers 4
et ensuite je prends donc on laisse la
tour en cinquième si les noirs bouge pas
leurs pions on va avancer notre propre
roi tranquillement et si les noirs
avancent leurs pions latent qui soit en
h2 et on va ramasser simplement tour
c'est un tour h 30
donc elle a coupé marie sur la cinquième
donc ça veut dire qu'elle a une très
très bonne connaissance des finales deux
tours semble t-il à lui a posé un piège
et elle connaissait très bien cette
finale apparemment faut couper le roi
sur la 5e et le rô le pion à l'air de
vouloir avancer
mais comme les blancs mais non les
blancs eux le roi protège le pion mais
pas les noirs c'est subtil c'est pas
facile à voir ici
torah 5 fait nul parce que ça empêche
les blancs d'avancer leurs pions et en
cas de roy c6 bien simplement
e
simplement je vous par exemple
sans doute t'auras 8 oui et la tour 1 à
8 va pourra revenir en b vite se
sacrifie contre le pion tous comme ça où
on peut le voir ailleurs mais c'est le
voit c'est cette ambition de voir sa
tour à 5,6 le roi les noirs viennent en
c6 maintenant je pousse h4 voilà et que
font les blancs si je pousse ça a l'air
bon ah oui tout simplement de reprendre
de suffire tout reprend reprend et
maintenant simplement oui h trois dames
des dames et rien n'y a pas de ramassage
de damas la fin donc c'est nul voyez
donc en fait voilà ici h4 père d'aller
voir marié rate pas incroyable b 6 h 3
17 et est bien là russe n'essaie même
pas de venir en b1 puisque si si les
noirs ou alors on simplement en sept ans
à cette même si vous c'est aussi bien
enfin moi en bien c'est pas mal si on
revient de b1 et bien simplement les
blancs comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
comme je vous expliquais fond dames
il faut bien sûr prendre la dame prend
droit et là que font les noirs le roi
est coupée donc on va laisser là relate
au 1/5 on touche pas au pire on fait
rien en fait on attend que le pion
viennent en h264 si les noirs font rien
moi j'avance leroy jamais le roi de ce
côté-là et ou par là je ne sais pas
enfin je oui j'ai sans doute par l'un et
quand les noirs jouent h 2
s'ils ne jouent pas avec le noir je vais
je vais l'a empêché à je peux toujours
jouer des coudes attentes avec la tour
sur la cinquième dès que les noirs
jouent h 2
simplement je fais tour c1 et le nom
n'ont pas le temps de venir le chercher
voilà il leur manque une case en fait
terminer je vous fais pas que roy et
tout rentrera ça gagne 1 voilà donc
bicis h3b 7 donc les noirs et s'est même
pas de prendre le public commence à se
rendre compte que ça va pas elle a dû
voir que ça allait pas dû s'en rendre
compte
on n'avait pas beaucoup de temps non
plus c'est sûr que d'am dam simplement
c'est aux blancs de jouer et on sait
très bien dans ce type de position
le premier qui fait d'armes derrière a
suffisamment d'échec pour faire maths et
c'est bien ce qui va se passer
échec alors là si le roi était venu en
f6 tout simplement il ya matt part
d'alger cinq échecs
si le noir vient par exemple f7 mais
c'est pareil s'il vient aussi son nom
est fait aux riches est donc là ici
simplement torres 5 échecs qui a pris
3,6 d'escalier échec échec et mat
ça vous connaissez très bien dames g8
échec donc là si on vient ici c'est matt
donc la con th 6 mais c'est matt aussi
c'est plus subtil
pour ces six échecs à noter que le nom
aurait pu sacrifier dame prend tour mais
bon c'est des grands maîtres roi plus
d'âme contre tour dames contre tours
elle sait très bien gagner samarie a pas
de problème
son adversaire le sait aussi donc elle
fait pas d'emprunt tour elle aurait pu
saler voulait jouer plutôt que de se
faire mater mais non elle va se faire
mater regarder le long de la colonne h
d'alger six échecs h quatre tours ces
quatre échecs pour h3 d'alger quatre
échecs et abandonneront puisqu'après roi
h2 simplement il va suivant tour ces
deux échecs on est obligé d'intercepter
par la dame et ensuite on prend la dame
avec matt incroyable magnifique victoire
de marie ces balles qui prend l'avantagé
donc dans ce huitième de finale dans une
partie à rebondissements de particules
aurait pu finir comme on l'a vu vers le
30e coup 30-30 entre le 30e 40e coup
mais a eu le manqué du temps pour
trouver cette combinaison
les noirs sont revenus dans la partie
mais ensuite marie à lui a posé un piège
de finale 1 c'est un piège de finale
qu'on a vu là toute une technique vous
avez vu bloquer le roi sur la 5eme
pousser son propre pions et on faire
croire à l'adversaire qui peut faire
dame comme nous et en fait non il peut
pas incroyable moi je connaissais pas ce
type d'astuces
et bien maintenant je connais enfin tout
cas je vais vue magnifique superbe
finale de grand maître de marie sebag
qui prend l'avantagé qui donc est très
bien placé maintenant pourquoi pas pour
se qualifier en quarts de finale est
arrivé en quart de finale tout est
possible tout est possible pour marie
c'est back bravo marie espérant qu'elle
craque pas bien sûr avec les noirs il
faut jamais vendre la peau de l'ours
et si elle arrivait à gagner ou à faire
nul demain eh bien ça lui permettrait
d'éviter les tie breaks dont de se
reposer avant le quart de finale
et bien c'est tout le mal qu'on lui
souhaite je vous laisse donc sur ce
résultat
juste un petit un petit oeil c'est
peut-être sur les autres matches il n'y
en a plus autant qu'avant on peut
regarder les résultats donc un pic aux
niveaux continuent à se balader
elle a gagné en cours sa partie ici ah
bon ça c'est des matches nuls qu'on
n'est pas les joueuses alexandra
kosteniuk a perdu donc ça c'est une
grosse surprise avec les blancs en plus
donc en position de se faire éliminer la
l'ex-champion du monde qu'akram ligne
par contre là remporté tranquillement et
puis la chinoise qui toujours en jeu a
gagné aussi est en fait stefanova aussi
l'ancien champion du monde a perdu avec
les blancs donc des grosses surprises là
kosteniuk et stefanova en grande
difficulté marie ses bagues en position
de se qualifier comme koné roues et bien
délai partie le regain d
en évitant les tie breaks donc voilà ça
laisse ça laisse de belles opportunités
1 à la numéro un française pour la suite
de ce championnat du monde 2015 final
voilà merci de m'avoir suivi sur d
honnêteté et je dis au revoir à une
prochaine fois